he's been a stabilizing force in
ensuring Ukraine has what it needs to
defend itself the American stands with
you and the world stands with you after
a year of unwavering support U.S
President Joe Biden's commitment to
Ukraine is unmatched with his country
allocating roughly 113 billion dollars
in Aid that doesn't count
the other half a billion dollars were
going to be we're announcing with you
today and tomorrow
ammunition and weaponry are the keys to
Ukraine unlocking Victory but they have
a heavy political price tag in May of
2022 60 percent of American adults were
in favor of providing weapons to Ukraine
in the weeks leading up to the one-year
anniversary that number has dipped to 48
percent if Ukraine is able to make
advances in the offensive that's
expected later in the spring I think
that will encourage people to believe
that this will not go on forever that
Victory Is Possible and therefore
support continuing aid while 11
Republicans have called for an end to
spending on Ukraine party leadership is
not on board that is essential
reinforcement for the Biden
Administration amid growing concerns
that China could become a Russian weapon
supplier any country that comes to their
age should pay a heavy price
China says its role is to urge peace and
to promote talks its foreign minister is
expected to travel to Russia soon
furthering its so-called No Limits
relationship with Moscow which could
further the rift with Washington there's
no question that if China provides
lethal Aid to Russia that will hurt U.S
Chinese relations it also provides
another hurdle for this U.S president to
overcome
Global News Washington